let's jump into this story man because
this this video is going viral and I'm
sure everybody's seen it Canadian TV
reporter suffers medical emergency live
on air telling hosts she's not feeling
well and slurs words before Eerie Blank
Stare let me let me see if we can play
this video
oh let me fix the I always I always do
this with the audio because I'm like
playing music this is hard to watch so I
haven't seen guys you haven't seen this
one it's a little hard to watch so which
one you know okay
oh it's so quiet
yeah it's still on the it's still on
this it's coming through the mics oh is
that it what yeah it's not it's not no I
assume it should be like no I changed it
it's not the right one oh there was a uh
it's on the right one it's just that
it's super low audio in chess you don't
kill pieces you capture them you make
them your slavery
don't kill them to sleep
now let's play this I'm boosting it up
week before the third anniversary
well people we spoke with say they were
happy that something is being done but
this is something that they've been
asking for since day one so for them
this is about a thousand days too late
now nevermind I'm looking at uh through
the the day families are pushing feds to
pushing the feds to
sorry Airman I'm
I'm not feeling very well right now and
I'm about just okay well come back to me
right now and we'll make sure that
Jessica you are doing okay thank you we
will dude look at that last part again
watch watch how she like her eyes just
zoom out
right there dude yeah right through you
thank you we will and then she's like
dude she fell yeah they cut away from
her she she hit the ground now
everybody's everybody's got their
theories of course this young woman uh
on TV look something like that stuff
like this has happened before so I don't
wanna I don't want to over hype this or
downplay it I just want to be like I
don't know I know what it is you know
absolutely I think it's very clear that
evidence is 100 there that this was
absolutely climate change that is
responsible for them it is Canada and
the weather has been really hot lately
there yeah and it makes sense also like
I think everyone at the equator is
already dead I think there's a reason
there's a migrant crisis here that the
so media is not telling us and uh I you
got to trust the science
yeah yeah actually look I think you're
right yeah look at the story from Vice
scientists studying temperature at which
humans spontaneously die with increasing
urgency what wet bulb conditions are
when heat and humidity can cause
otherwise healthy humans to overheat and
die they're happening more often than
ever oh that explains it she's wearing a
thick coat I know it's cold out but the
humidity is building up she's having a
wet bulb inside of her thing you know
and her brain just starts boiling in her
head and then she's like oh then she
goes down that's crazy is this something
you would expect to see on the Babylon b
or something and that's not the first
article there
any articles like this making the same
kind of argument that there has been a
slight change in temperatures and
therefore this is causing people to drop
dead uh suddenly you know what yeah
they've just been dropping dead for
years but I think it's more common now
right it's more common Sports it is for
sure look at this article right here
look at August 2022. rise in heart
disease may be explained by extreme
weather conditions let's look it's
climate change so it's not above the
clock your arteries look at look at this
look at this it says it's not clear why
temperature shifts correlate with more
heart attacks then why are you reporting
it
that's a good question see this is this
is proof that people will believe
anything and Democrats exploit this all
the time exactly they are exploit naive
people no no I figured it out yeah if
we're if we're playing the correlation
game I got a lot of things correlates uh
heart attacks are linked with Joe Biden
draining the petroleum reserves to be
when Biden started offloading all of our
petroleum reserves people started
getting real bad anxiety causing heart
attacks yeah even in 15 year olds yeah
there's 15 year olds on the soccer field
they're like
if we're gonna play this game of
correlate correlation in there like you
see the one where they said unvaccinated
are more likely to get in car accidents
yeah
are they telling us to follow the signs
which if they're falling inside just
because we have a causation doesn't mean
that's actually what's causing it yeah
yeah it just because you have a
correlation doesn't mean conversation
what else what else is going on this
past year that would be fun to uh
correlate into all these people having
heart attacks racism clearly you know
the rise of racism y'all seen the fat
black women say they're fat because of
white people
too is caused by racism caused by racism
no no so what's another major thing that
happened in this uh in this past year
like big news advantage in the Middle
East that probably oh oh dude I mean a
lot of heart attacks are probably caused
by Joe Biden's botched Afghanistan
withdrawal hands down there's a lot of
uh there's a lot of GMO mosquitoes too
they just started vaccinating the bees
that's going to work out really well
Bill Gates is doing really a cool stuff
yeah
anxiety oh hey hey shout out uh New York
Times if you're listening I got a good
one for you say write an article that
says anxiety over World War III because
of Putin's invasion is causing heart
attacks boom and now what you do is when
some like 17 year old kid has collapse
on the field again because we have
hundreds of these stories you just be
like you know we talk to his parents and
yes they talk like you ask the parents
have you ever talked about Russia you
did boom there it is now we have
evidence yeah now you can say we asked
the parents if they'd ever spoken about
Russia they said yes their kids had
heart attack does it bother you to think
that we might go to World War III if
they say yes then you know that's
indicates stress not so much as the
heart attack you know what it's crazy
growing up when I was in the military
there was a bunch of these athletes
having heart attacks on the fields and
they was able to link it within like
maybe a couple of months that it was
linked to a pre-workout it had some type
of caffeine that was linked to wow yeah
similar to it it's like yeah yeah and
they was able to get rid of it but we've
got all these people dropping their need
and they're trying to say this because
uh climate change yeah do you think they
would locate the the car yes yeah I mean
these are scientists y'all remember when
Kobe first broke they could name it to
the second to who was done in India who
was dying in Texas who was down in
Florida and it's like a night it was
like a voting map election night
remember when those videos were from
China were coming out of people dropping
dead suddenly right at the beginning of
covet right that was talked about that
was on the media this really isn't
remember that nurse they got that
vaccination vaccinated lab and she just
passes out yeah I was like I really
ain't taking that [ __ ] you know
I think I think the problem we're having
is that as the media lies more and more
as we expose more and more the media
lies people will literally either
believe or not believe anything you've
got a tribal element of it where you've
got people on the left who are like I'm
gonna believe whatever the media says no
matter what and even push the lies
because they're an occult then you got
people on the other side who are just
like don't care I'm not gonna believe it
that's a problem either way you cut it
yeah yeah like proper thinking on both
sides yeah but so I guess what I'm
thinking of is that Yuri besmanov and if
you guys ever see it oh yeah the Russian
he's like the former Soviet guys explain
how to destroy a country he's saying
make sure no one knows what's true and
quite literally us that we're trapped in
it right right we're out outside
outright being like this story is the
you're more likely to get in a car
accident because you didn't get
vaccinated that's probably because you
live in the middle of nowhere and
probably because you don't drive that
often yeah yeah you know what um you
know what the cause of all the of our
problems I'm trying to backwards you're
more likely to drive than you are if you
were in a city yeah um the reason why
we're having so many problems in this
country it's not because of these
politicians if the media did that job
like they supposed to do that's why we
have the First Amendment to keep our
politicians accountable when you are in
a communist country you don't have a
media but that's why we have the first
amendment in this country and not
because our media won't do the right
thing hold both sides accountable that's
why we're in the position we're in yeah
it's like what's the point of having the
media if you're not gonna you're just
gonna you know stand up for the left or
you're just gonna stand up for the right
there's a lot more of that going on on
the left but yeah stuff like this this
is not journalism and they're grossly
negligent about the kid what was the the
pro-life um school that was going to do
a pro-life March at the Capitol and that
yeah man it was like yeah Nick salmon
yeah yeah yeah
they end up having to pay that guy like
how much like hundreds of millions of
dollars but they they ran that store
because they got to paint Trump
supporters as like these evil racist
people and that's why you got people
dude they're pod people yeah you see
that you said thing of uh Jimmy Fallon
singing about xbb 1.5 oh my God yeah
he's a pod person man pot people can't
get humor it's like an alien coming here
like in The Matrix when uh that guy is
like everything tastes like chicken
because the robots don't know what
things taste like right yeah the pod
people don't know how to do jokes so
they're like doing these really
off-putting facsimiles of humor it
doesn't work or Klaus Schwab is like
dance now and he's like okay
poor guy I mean he could see the soul
just being sucked out of his life in
existence on this Earth X1 BB one point
my poor guy I mean can you imagine can
you imagine the human suffering just
just how low you have to think of
yourself to be such a stooge
backstage yeah seriously
Stephen Colbert did it like what a
couple years ago the vaccine yeah he did
he did a vaccine dance he actually did a
whole bunch yeah yeah he did a bunch of
it was a it's a black dating app what
was the name of that dating app oh it
came with their vaccine you remember it
was like a rap song it was ratchet and
he was [ __ ] oh my God
it was a black dating app just for black
people yeah so you already know this rap
song it's gonna be ratcheted [ __ ] and
they're rapping about getting vaccinated
yeah it was and then the lead singer was
a trans yeah and I'm not sure which way
it was a trans girl physical was it
backs that ass up something like that
yeah I think that I think I think I saw
that yeah and Max that ass up I was like
look at it like
is this really how y'all see black
people [ __ ] this is how you're gonna
approach them and Market them a vaccine
is this that's that thing up yeah yep
there's a juvenile is that juvenile yes
that was juvenile too yeah my goodness
wow there's a spin-off for his song yeah
and everybody's coming it's like is that
a dude oh he remixed Back That Thing You
yeah that thing up maybe that's a missed
Back That Thing Up yeah it was so
remarkably bad do you guys uh you can
play it you guys see this story uh well
I was gonna bring this one up the
basketball player who uh who collapsed
on the court I didn't hear about that
yeah yeah this one this one also went
file take a look we'll play this oh wow
I didn't see this wait I just want to
make sure the volume is not too loud
it's college right this is uh this is
college right here look at this dude
your eyes number three number three
right there boom watch this he starts
grabbing his chest then slowly goes down
to the ground players from both teams
visibly upset after watching take a look
that wasn't because they know it wasn't
basketball that caused it that wasn't
commotion Cardis no yeah you know when
that when uh nothing hit him that
football player got tackled you know so
I I I've asked a medical professional
and they said well that one could be
like and this is somebody who's like
complaining about the vaccines we have
we have a you know Medical Professional
we know but you know what's crazy it's
never happened before I watch football
in football perhaps yeah in football
yeah so it's like it was the guy in the
50s he had a blood clot but he had a
blood clot and then he like died in the
field in the 70s 71 71 yeah something
like that so right at the end of the
game too
it could be I'm not going to sit here
and pretend it is you know I mean like
the media is going to come out and be
like always you know it's commercial
Cardis and better parents got to watch
it for their kids and it's like if that
was that was like winning the lottery
yeah exactly that's what about so what
are the chances of that happen it
happens in baseball because a hard
projectile is projectile is thrown at
like 30 to 50 miles an hour or whatever
hits a kid right above the heart and
then stuns their heart yeah but this guy
you have pads to come down like this
yeah that's like well look man this guy
just fell down for no reason yeah yeah
and he's got it up quick and then he
feels like this one and then they they
brought him the bench and they're
sending him to a Cardiologist so he just
he just went down my uh my uh guy that
travels with us does shows he got the
backs because he had to for work so he
didn't have no choice and he was on
stage he opens for us remember that time
yeah the episode he had an episode up on
stage where his chest started hurting
really bad and he got pale and he's a
black guy and he wasn't feeling good he
he had to cut his set and call us out
sooner and he's like dude I don't know
why he said man my chest was just like
it was hurting and I couldn't breathe
out short of breath I was like are you
fine nice like yeah I'm fine but he said
I don't know if they'll happen I think I
just hyperventilated
everybody has a choice yeah that choice
might be you get to be homeless and live
in the woods and you might starve to
death like you know certainly it's
coercive elements but you had you have a
choice I think for you know look I I
don't know what's causing any of this
and I'm not going to pretend to know I'm
gonna say talk to a doctor but I'm gonna
tell you if you feel a certain way about
what's going on you better make you
better make the choice you think is
going to keep you alive yeah I mean I I
bought a car like about a year ago and I
was doing my paperwork with the finance
guy and he shared a story with me about
his daughter
he's like this is right when the uh you
know the uh the Alki came out the fact I
actually came out and he said his
daughter wants to travel and go to
Europe but because of covety she
couldn't do it but not because the
vaccine was out you can go travel in
Europe and go to all these great
placements you have to be vaccinated so
she got vaccinated and two weeks before
she took off the uh to go on her trip
she dropped dead of a blood clot wow
she's in her early 20s
so he told me he's like dude if you if
if you're healthy he's like dude I
wouldn't that's what he told me
personally and well so I I I had a
summer thing when I talked to a doctor
so like I I I did not get the vaccine
right I talked to a doctor and they said
this was this was back before uh this
was around the time when they were like
we don't know how many we got and they
were like you're young you're you're not
in the risk factor right you exercise
let someone else get it you're you're
not the person for us like someone who's
70 needs this when I got sick we went to
the doctor you know everybody knows that
story but uh I talked to a doctor and
that's what they told me I think for a
lot of people they got mad because their
doctors and the doctors were like don't
know don't care just do it or a lot of
people like pulled up at 7-Eleven
parking lots right my thing was like
look
ask your doctor questions about the news
and what's going on ask them like hey
man you know I heard this story if they
can if they can properly inform you and
they and you trust them then take your
doctor's advice but but there's a lot of
people who are complaining because their
doctors don't seem to know what's going
on and I'm like that's like hiring a
plumber doesn't fix a toilet yeah you
know what I mean like find a doctor who
knows what's going on and get some good
medical advice I think they have a
financial incentive to recommend the
shot too and that's a conflict of
interest not just that but like opiates
in any drug right that's a big problem
too yeah yeah we definitely learned a
lot through the opioid epidemic but just
the bigger picture being that doctors
recommend drugs because pharmaceutical
companies make money off of it they send
them free samples I hurt my knee when I
was a kid skating and the doctor handed
me like five like bundles of steroid
samples like here you need this for an
anti-inflammatory and I was just like
what is this yeah so how do you fix that
though with doctors well I I understand
that I think you make people understand
that doctors could be as easily bought
off as politicians right
um and and I think you make people
prioritize their own health and I think
at the you know what the best kind of
medical advice I could give anybody is
to do what is right for them and every
individual is unique everyone's
different but we also have to realize
that there is a war on your health
there's a lot of very powerful people
that are interested in making you fat
and making you sad and making you
infertile and a lot of this war is waged
through our food so I think uh just just
living as an example I think educating
people and telling people as much as we
can this is what I do this is what I
focus on a lot especially with my
members area oops sorry there I remember
area specifically focusing and talking
about a lot of these issues on a
one-on-one kind of personal basis and
when I go to the doctor I travel a lot
and I see a lot of different doctors out
there and I and I always kind of ask and
I'm like hey you you did you
and you know based on that conversation
or based off him even uh or her asking
me hey what's your diet what's your
stress levels uh how's your sleep
schedule uh what are you are you doing
any physical exercise if the doctor's
asking me that then I know the doctor's
actually incentivized to uh helping me
and and taking care of me otherwise
they're just like here take these pills
automatically that's a red flag and that
should be a red flag for a lot of people
you know what I found most alarming
about the pandemic when they start
recommending this the uh the the shot
even if you had already contracted the
virus yeah
really weird yeah yeah because like who
gets chickenpox and then go gets the
chickenpox vaccine well I think you're
not supposed to I'm not the doctor yeah
from what I'm told is you get a vaccine
to help your body kick up an immune
response so that you don't get really
sick from the thing if you already got
sick from the thing don't get the
vaccine because your body's already
kicked up the immune response that's
what I'm told that's what a lot of
doctors were saying and then they were
the ones that were censored they're the
ones that were kicked out uh there was
uh two famous doctors from California
came out and and did a video
specifically about this that video has
taken off of YouTube what I did like is
you're good oh now when I called the
doctor they said explicitly you cannot
get the vaccine if you've had covid you
have to wait they said you have to wait
like a month or two or something like
that it's crazy people that got it got
the vaccine and the damn boost yeah and
it's like Dr Falcon was pushing that
idea it's like no you uh because they
wasn't they didn't they hadn't
determined yet how long your immunity
was up after getting covered when he's
been doing this for decades he has a
good idea that your immunity just just
doesn't run out in a year yeah we give
blood like every what what four months
six months and six months two years that
since I got coveted I still hadn't I
still had the antibodies from coffee
yeah and I caught it twice the second
time was nothing that first time was
rough the president the first time we
got it it was the worst thing I ever
experienced oh yeah my feet turned blue
oh wow my feet turned blue yeah and me
and Kevin was calling each other every
hour every couple I say making you still
breathe or you die
trying to filter that garbage out of
your body but my feet turned blue and I
was like man this is because I've had
the fluid but this that covet it was
that's the crazy thing too and I kept
hearing people say like oh it's like the
flu and I'm like not for me dude y'all
remember y'all remember the Republican
they say it's just a flu it's just a bad
food I got covered I said [ __ ]
so at first I was like
other people got sick before me and then
I'm all like I'm not gonna get sick you
know I'm eating I'm eating right and I'm
I'm exercising and then a day or two
later I'm like I'm feeling sick it's not
so bad all work and then it worked the
next day I'm like wow I feel really sick
I don't think I can work today I'm gonna
have to lay down right right the next
day it was so bad I was shaking yeah I
actually I called local hospital and
they said what do you want us to do it's
a virus and I was like is there a
protocol is there like no IV fluids or
whatever like no stay home good luck
yeah exactly later that night I was so
bad that I was like I'm not going to
wait around to find out that I'm gonna
I'm going to the hospital or something I
don't want to you know figure out what's
going to be but I was I was breathing
heavy so I I know Joe talked a lot about
it on his show about right his treatment
yeah and I was like bro I got bad I'm
feeling like death what's up and then he
was just I told him like I called the
hospital they said nothing he's like no
no call like a private practice tell
them what you're experiencing they can
give you something anything like here's
the thing even if you're sick they can
give you IV fluids because that'll
that'll help you you're dehydrated right
like these doctors will help you out so
the challenge is a lot of these
treatments like monoclonal antibodies is
2 500 per per treatment oh wow so sure
enough we're we're lucky enough to be
able to have this uh taken care of right
and uh we actually got everybody the
treatment but like overnight I was
better yeah it was crazy you know it's
uh we're like um when I was wasn't
feeling well my wife was real concerned
she was like a big time cover space
right so she sent me down to the clinic
to find out within 24 hours the rapid
response
so
I get the rapid response Destiny call
you back and um and I called back and I
called at least you're you have covered
and it's funny I was one of those guys
just the flu was just the flu so when
she told me that I had constantly oh man
I'm gonna freaking die that was like my
first response yeah yeah hey Echo Health
Alliance spent a lot of your tax dollars
uh weaponizing a virus and they did a
good job at it thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time